Importanța calculului cuantic este atât subestimată
cât și exagerată enorm în același timp.
Deși nu va înlocui calculatoarele convenționale,
inovația cuantică reprezintă o nouă paradigmă de calcul.
Calculatoarele cuantice pot lucra în unison cu infrastructura de calcul actuală
pentru a rezolva probleme complexe care anterior erau
considerate impractice sau imposibile.
Asta poate schimba paradigma.
De exemplu, dificultatea de a factoriza numerele mari
în numerele lor prime stă la baza criptografiei moderne.
Pentru dimensiunea numerelor utilizate în criptografia modernă cu cheie publică
privată, acest calcul ar dura
cel mai rapid calculator convențional peste 300 de trilioane de ani.
Pentru un calculator cuantic la scară largă care lucrează
cu algoritmul lui Shor, acest calcul ar putea dura câteva secunde.
Probleme complexe ca aceasta există în toate industriile.
Aplicațiile potențiale ale calculului cuantic
sunt vaste.
Calculatoarele cuantice cresc deja din ce în ce mai mult
și devin tot mai capabile,
pe măsură ce urmărim să abordăm probleme mai complicate.
Din 2016, IBM a pus calculatoarele cuantice la dispoziția
publicului printr-un site web cu o interfață grafică care
arată ca o partitură muzicală.
și kitul de dezvoltare software Qiskit
care permite utilizatorilor să programeze calculatoare cuantice.
Oamenii de știință din interiorul și din afara lumii corporatiste
rulează experimente
prin portale similare. Explorează abordări ale problemelor de chimie
și machine learning, încercând să înțeleagă
ce tipuri de întrebări pot pune
și cum vor formula acele întrebări
odată ce tehnologia va avansa mai mult. Acum este
momentul potrivit pentru liderii de afaceri să se pregătească
pentru cuantic. Condițiile sunt la locul lor pentru a experimenta
și a extinde această tehnologie fundamental nouă.
Organizațiile care doresc să fie în
fruntea acestei schimbări transformaționale vor
obține avantaj competitiv. Acest training
te va pregăti să îți începi călătoria cuantică!